welcome to iced coffee hour we are wall
street bets
what an introduction
thanks so much it's great you're very
welcome how are you guys we are in the
presence i think of greatness here
i hope so well i'm equally as happy to
be here and equally as thrilled thank
you so much so uh tell us a little bit
about your story uh the creation of wall
street bets your involvement how this
came to be a little bit about the
backstory of everything
so i
started wall street bets about 10 years
ago give or take right like i've been a
serial entrepreneur my whole life right
out of college i've had some really
successful companies i've had some big
flops right but i uh
one of the companies that i sold ended
up being
a paper millionaire company right like
it was just this great deal it was the
first one that i'd started from scholar
college and it turned out that a lot of
those papers ended up being useless
right so i was like all right clearly
i'm missing a finance component
start getting the finance studying it
you know i got myself a job at a big
multinational bank and uh and making
decent money i'm like all right cool i'm
gonna keep my 401k i'm gonna do my
typical retirement but i'm gonna put my
extra money to work right and it's
looking for places online that was uh
condu conductive or conducive to higher
risk trading right like for these things
that i can win the lottery overnight and
just retire happy
but there was no place like that it was
either like conventional
diversified low commission etf type
investing or professional traders right
these are people that just do like look
at charts all day long and i just wanted
to have some fun so i started wall
street bets
now when you mean you started wall
street bets we're talking about the
subreddit
on reddit well it was a whole yeah so it
was a subreddit on reddit that's correct
yeah and and
what do you call it twitter account
youtube you know like the platform
there's a lot of different ones i wasn't
sure which one was going to be the one
that was going to grow right and so
the
the subreddit was the one that ended up
just organically growing right like
people often ask me how did you grow it
so much and it was just people were
interested in it yeah right like it was
now why create a community why wouldn't
this just be you having fun by yourself
maybe with some buddies in a you know
texting back and forth a little bit why
create a community around that because i
don't know what i'm doing
right like i know what the stocks are i
know the stock market is and i started
looking at stock options i'm like these
are cool right like they go up and down
really fast with fairly little money so
i'm hoping somebody can give me some
tips right like it was just
wanting to learn and also wanting to
share that with somebody and uh and wall
street bets ended up attracting a
perfect mix of both well not
professionals but people that really
know what they're doing and people that
really want to learn what they're doing
and
made a wonderful combination right so
you were just looking for high-risk
places to put your money in
and you were doing yolo bets and stuff
like that and then you wanted to make a
community around it
effectively yeah i mean i would like i
don't know which one it was a chicken or
the egg situation but i wanted to
do high risk it wasn't like so much yolo
bet it was i want to get rich quick
right which requires yolo and you know
like risk and return are the same thing
and so if i'm going to get a scratch off
lottery ticket this is at least more fun
i can do it from my phone
uh back in the day there wasn't
commission free they were just low
commission uh brokers that were just
starting to kick out so i was like oh
cool this is a couple bucks like when i
first invested in the stock market it
was thirty dollars to buy shares and
thirty dollars to sell them yeah what
brokerage was that
that was i don't remember but i was
but
using
like
called wachovia now it's wells fargo
yeah acquired multiple times but it was
just through like the bank
it was like we have to call up a guy on
the phone
jim placed this trade for me
that's pretty much how it was but then
the the broker that i used to use a lot
was options house which then turned into
e-trade but it was just you know like
eventually when they start off with a
little capital they have this rule
called the pattern day trader you need
to have 25 grand in order to do multiple
trade like lots of day trades and i
didn't have 25 grand so i was like uh
i'm gonna use this broker and then i'm
gonna get that broker and i'm gonna use
that broker so that every time i open a
new there's no rule that says how many
brokers you can have so right yeah and
it's something that people still do
today
that's crazy at the time was that a
sizeable amount of money for you that
you were you know putting in you know
call options you know like i was
probably putting a couple thousand like
i
i
i think i might have funded the account
with either 10 or 20 grand right but it
was just all right let's see let's see
what i'm willing to do like anything
over 25 i think that was just a
psychological barrier and the word
pattern daytrader was like man i have to
click more little boxes it says i really
need to know what i'm doing i'm going to
get into like
above my water but yeah
you know like in the fluctuations that
take place when you when you're taking
such high risk trades especially with
stock options like i would make 20 grand
and then i would lose 40 grand and i
would like refill the machine with more
money
very appropriate now that i'm in vegas
and like okay game over and like play
again and then just keep going up
probably ended up breaking even probably
lost money uh during the first few years
but it was just a wild
great learning experience how much were
you making back then you're working
full-time right yeah i was probably
making 150 grand okay so and i was
single i didn't have you know any
dependents like i had a nice car but i
preferred to take the metro to work
right so like i really my expenses were
pretty much rent right and uh
and i could afford to take whatever risk
i wanted to but at the same time were
you also investing in like you know etfs
and stuff like that no no sorry in my
roth r uh yeah
yeah yeah yeah that was through my
employer they do the whole matching
thing or whatever but everything on top
of that was just yeah i would do i would
do stock options on the s p i would do
stock options on that day yeah what was
community like back then
at what point did it grow to like the
first ten thousand people or or the
point where you knew that this is its
own community separate from everything
else
there's a lot of moments throughout the
time so like i start this thing off and
well first i register and then i take a
few months kind of trying to decide
exactly how it's going to look and what
it's going to be about and then i
finally announced it like five six
months later
and on similar subreddits and on my
twitter with six followers on whatever
and people started showing up and it
would double in size
pretty much every year right so like
maybe from a thousand to two to four to
eight and then very soon you're at like
five 000 it turns to a million all right
like you start doubling things that
really grow fast but it was it was
immediately apparent when when i could
see kind of like the curve of
uh the growth and then there were
moments where where we say ah we made it
right i remember in it it was april
fool's of 2004
no 2015 i believe
me and the other mods were just real
jokesters right like we had this
keep it fun and keep it simple and so
for april fool's day
one of the most
turn the you know you can change the
interface you can make it look however
you want and he put like
shifted the entire thing slightly so
that it was just annoying or it made you
think your screen was off and it was
like windows 95 type icons and it had
these twirling
we're like
[Laughter]
and on that day just serendipity we had
uh
i want to say it's like fortune.com or
one of those
uh big websites we're saying okay yeah
we're talking about volatility
instruments blah blah blah there's a
forum where they think something
something's gonna happen and then the
word forum was a link and he clicked the
link and it took you straight to wall
street bets so we're all excited because
finally somebody saw wall street bets
right but we were twice as
thrilled about the fact that this was on
april fools so we can just imagine the
number of people sitting at or reading
fortune clicking
clicking the link and being greeted by
these
non-safe for work
so how do you how do you monetize the
subreddit because it's one thing to
create a fun community as a side hobby
but at what point are you able to turn
that into a business or figure out a way
to monetize that uh you cannot monetize
the sub right now like by the rules not
by what efforts you can do right and so
i was actually removed in 2020 because i
wrote a book and i started this while i
was before covet created this kind of
competitive day trading competition that
was the
excuse as to why they were moving reddit
never really told me but there is a rule
there that says you can right
um
not allowed to talk about the actual
story because they're actually making a
movie i sold my life rights to a movie
studio and so they're going to
be the ones who get to tell that story
but that's kind of a tangent how do you
monetize a brand that is a different
story right like i have the trademark i
have you know i wrote the book and i
have a gazillion different things under
that umbrella
that is monetizable so i guess the
closest you could get to monetizing
something on reddit would be
to create a brand and kind of grow an
audience similar to the way that you
would do this on youtube or tick tock or
whatever it might be and then kind of
build it out that way sure so reddit is
a policy against not directly monetizing
a subreddit but you could own the
trademark
and then license the trademark
yeah so it gets like a way around it no
no no this is something
yeah yeah i've spent a ton of time on
this right like
it's really strange because you can have
coca-cola
or underarm or whatever brand you want
like that monetize it and then come to
reddit and they say hey this is my brand
we'd like to be able to
uh grow the community and get them
involved and monetize this component of
it right but if you start from scratch
and say this is my brand like or you
want to turn it into one
then it gets kind of tricky the rule is
you cannot be paid to moderate that's
the actual rule uh which in my case or
whatever i'm not going to talk about my
case but that's um
yeah that's the rule that's in place
reddit turns around
when they see a subreddit that starts uh
growing a lot they turn around and try
to trademark that name they've done that
with explain it like i'm five they've
done it like i forget which ones they
are i know this because uh currently in
a battle with reading they're not happy
with my trademark of wall street mets
right but um but it is kind of a really
weird
thing i don't think reddit thought it
through when they first started it i've
been watching them forever when they
were really small they're like oh this
is really cool
uh a lot of people come here let's hold
hands kumbaya and then they realize
there's potential conflicts there and
yeah if you have the trademark
specifically if you have the one that uh
involves internet forums and chat rooms
and all type of social social networking
then
then it gets interesting first we have
to thank our sponsor helix sleep so i
actually recently bought a house and i
have to say i am so grateful for my
helix sleep mattress seriously guys i
moved in without even having a fridge
without wi-fi and without even having
like trash service but i made sure i did
not move in without my helix sleep
mattress why didn't you just stay at
grams well that's besides the point alex
plus i slept like a baby the magic
behind it is their sleep quiz see helix
knows everyone sleeps different so if
you guys head over to
helixsleep.comcoffee you can take their
sleep quiz in under two minutes and it
will match you to the perfect mattress
when i took the quiz i was actually
matched with the helix plus which is for
plus size sleepers that's the first time
i've ever heard of any mattress made for
plus size sleepers so there really is a
mattress out there for everyone and they
even have a 10 year warranty and you can
also sleep on the mattress 100 nights
risk free because if you don't like it
they'll come and pick it up for you but
guys i promise you will love it so
revolutionize the way that you sleep
with a mattress made for you right now
they're actually giving two hundred
dollars off all mattress orders and
two free pillows if you go to
helixsleep.com
coffee that's helixsleep.comcoffee
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows that's right helixsleep.com
coffee thank you so much helix for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast i'd almost imagine that reddit
now would have learned from uh those
experiences and just made it like a
terms of the agreement where like by
signing here uh and making an account
you agree that anything you create on
the side it belongs to us
so i i don't know if they think that
would discourage some people that are
creating forums though from no doing it
i don't think so at all because i think
the people that create forums never
do it for the intention of making money
i think you were a perfect example of
that you just created because you wanted
to do that i don't think that would
discourage anyone from being like oh
well i can't monetize it i'm not gonna
make this community anymore yeah and
somebody else would
yeah i mean it is an interesting balance
right like so reddit starts off as
literally let's just you know i think at
one point they were taking donations
they just want it to be a great
community and i loved reddit right like
still is a great platform and uh back in
2010 or so they organized this huge
rally it wasn't right at the company but
it was like the community that got
together in washington dc where i was
living at the time they got together
like 100 000 people and they filled up
the
uh the national mall and they had this
event with stephen colbert and the other
guy jon stewart and i had a bunch of
celebrities on it was like wow this is
really like this is a huge deal right
and so right at that point kind of got
involved with it
uh
and then all of a sudden big money
starts rolling in they you know they
sold it and they bought it back and then
now they're considering going public
with this and so i think their original
model wasn't really a business model it
was more this is for everybody you know
by the people for the people type thing
and then eventually they're like all
right well we gotta pay the servers it's
a lot of traffic yeah we got to start
doing some things and then yeah one
thing led to the next now they want to
do an ipo which now forces their epider
you know the financial statements to be
nice and
uh clean with that so they're still kind
of maneuvering it but i don't think it's
well defined right like it's a weird
thing
that you register a subreddit and then
if it gets big then they subjectively go
and try and get it right like there's a
bunch of other ones like satoshi street
bets and other ones where they don't
seem to care about but couldn't they
argue that that's for the benefit of
let's say let's say i'm looking at that
and finding like bitcoin bets let's just
say that that's a subreddit i see it
getting big i didn't create it but i
could go and register the trademark for
that can't i can't just any random
person go and do that so it's better for
reddit to do that
and some random look i get that point i
understand they want to they want to be
able to protect it right because
especially if something gets bigger like
something like wall street bets and
that's pretty much a threat uh trademark
laws thankfully they're relatively fair
all right so when you all go to
trademark someone they're gonna be like
well
show me that you've used it right or
show me that you have the intention to
be used if nobody's used it before and
as part of that process uh
you know one of the one of the final
steps is they publish this trademark
application to the world and anyone that
has any objections can come in and say
no if you grant that person that
trademark that's going to harm my
business right and so then that starts
the whole process got it so what are
your thoughts now about how wall street
bets has evolved do you think today it's
the same
feeling or the same intention as it was
back when you started it or do you think
it's evolved and taking a life of its
own and it's different from
what you first had in mind
it's it's shifted uh as it's grown but
it has a lot of things that still
that are still the same right the
community gets started and it is a fun
honest like brutally unapologetic
place for people to to to hang out and
to learn and so this is yeah oftentimes
i get the question like so why do people
brag about their losses and on wall
street best i'm like it's not so much
that they're bragging even if it looks
like it maybe there is a little bit of
kind of flexing there but it's more
this is real all right this is in the
real world you you both win and lose
money and in this case i got my ass
handed to me so
give me like a virtual hug right and and
uh and same thing like look how much
money i made or sometimes look how much
money i made and then look how much i
just lost it again uh but this
you know let's let's have fun it's just
been no filter offensive uh a lot of the
times right there's just a lot of
locker room banter it's been
predominantly male for
as long as i can remember
so
that that hasn't changed but it started
shifting like some of the some of the
aspects of it which i wasn't happy with
and still
is you have some of this unapologetic
offensive speech turn into
hate speech right and you starts to it
becomes counterproductive
or even though there's no political like
there's just here we're talking about
stocks or
betting or whatever we're not deviating
from this including politics right just
to make sure
make this nice uh
silo of it
you know people do start
um
deviating in that direction so some of
that i think is because it's grown so
much and so you have slightly less
control but the
the overall tone of fun of really
creative really smart people that have
come up
wall street bets became real famous here
with gamestop right but as you know
because you had a podcast of about this
couple
years ago where these people took out
infinite leverage
right and prior to that they've done
other stuff that was similar like with
the box like there's been really clever
these people come together and they say
let's exploit an inefficiency and they
do it right that was wall street bets
the robin hood infinite money glitch
wow that was the original i completely
forgot about that yeah it was like two
years ago
jeez i i love that guy we had him on so
for those that are not aware this guy
found a loophole in robin hood where
i forget exactly how it worked but he
was basically
he was taking on margin
i think he was selling options or he's
he was doing something with options and
then selling those options so robin had
gave him a credit back but because he
still has that position but he got a
credit back robin hood then doubled his
margin and he was able to do it again
and then he would double his margin
again and so with like two grand he was
able to get like 1.7 million dollars
worth of margin
and uh
the the downside with this is that it
doesn't seem like
i would play it smarts like i think if
you want 1.7 million of the margin at
least do something where you have a high
likelihood of making money because you
know you have to pay at some point
they're going to learn about it but it
just seems so many people at that time
were just making these ridiculous bets
with like a 100 chance of like being big
and then they would lose it and just
delete the app
and uh
but you know what like i i guess we
could kind of talk about this now it's
been two years
um
robin hood uh i hope i could talk about
it anyway go for it my understanding is
that uh robin hood settled a lot of
these cases for pennies on the dollar so
someone would oh like two million bucks
and robin would be like hey just just
we'll call it this amount could pay us
off over time we'll call it even like
they got out good but i think robin hood
is afraid that uh these people could
lawyer up and be like well you allowed
some 18 year old kid to get on infinite
margin in a way that your platform
encouraged and allowed he's not
responsible for that loss that's a
glitch on your platform he doesn't have
the money plus here's the thing when
you're 19 you have no assets you have no
money to pay for what are they going to
collect they have a judgment against you
1.7 oh i i'm bankrupt now oh so i go on
social media and talk about that yeah
and they're the bad guys like
no but you know what's interesting about
that so like when that you know part of
when i started wall street bets i'm
looking at i'm on the heels of financial
crisis right like i'd actually lost a
job to the financial crisis so to some
extent i you know and i lived in dc
where a lot of the occupy wall street
moved so i had all these things fresh on
my mind and i started learning about
these things called leveraged etfs and
these are like these exotic variety
which are just basically math formulas
and and i was like how can these things
exist and why are they legal and didn't
we just learn a lesson this thing is
you know the counterparty risk and if
you're not supposed to be able to share
sell short unless you know you have the
collateral or experience but you can buy
an inverse etf and somebody else is
taking on the infinite risk and weird
stuff right so i'm matt and i write this
entire blog post
and i was like i'm going to publish this
and the whole world is going to be just
as outraged as me but first we have to
thank our sponsor ritual protein powders
can be extremely intimidating especially
with their very confusing ingredients
list and also just like the overall
perception of them but fortunately
ritual is here to shake things up but
the truth is we all need protein and
it's not just for building muscle we
need it at a cellular level so rituals
team of scientists reimagine protein
powder from the ground up the result is
a delicious plant-based protein offered
in three premium formulations for
distinct life stages and unique
nutritional needs all made with the same
high standards approach and commitment
to traceability that ritual is known for
i personally take rituals daily shake
powder every single day twice a day in
the mornings i mix it with my banana
smoothie and then before my workout i
dry scoop it jack you don't dry scoop it
i've seen you mix it with your oat milk
well i i have dry scooped it but
come on dude that's besides the point so
why not shake up your ritual to make
trying something new less scary they
have a 100 money back guarantee if you
don't love it so head over to ritual.com
ich to get your essential proteins today
and if you're an iced coffee hour
listener you actually get ten percent
off your first three months ten percent
off ten percent off oh my god all they
gotta do is go to ritual.com
ich trust me guys i love this stuff
thank you so much ritual for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast and
i was like nah no one's going to read my
blog post you know instead that's what
i'm like i can't beat them join them i'm
going to start going you know i'm going
to start using these leveraged etfs with
stock options on top of them to do some
crazy things
and then let people
you know let let people become outraged
on how we use this and and and and
that's how you look you'll
end up starting this dialogue right and
that's why i called it wall street bets
is i wanted to to make a statement there
that this is the casino right and this
is a lot of fun
that ethos continued to grow which
also was
right around the time when bitcoin
started also a similar language and
philosophy in mind right with like f the
central bank and the whole system but
anyways but this is
where we're
we're hoping to spark a conversation so
throughout this entire time
you get you fast forward to this moment
where these people take on risk that
they cannot handle right like well i
don't have that money like you know
if if
uh if the banks were able to do this in
2008 they didn't have the money and they
got bailed out i was like well then come
get me i got i don't have a million
dollars to see this is now your problem
is the typical if you owe the dollar the
bank a dollar it's your problem if you
owe them a million it's theirs like this
is kind of that and that continued
through well today and then obviously
with gamestop and these other the
philosophy so do you worry that it's
leaning a little bit too much into
gambling versus investing oh that's a
great question um no no no like
so you have
you have putting your money and hoping
that you get returns
as a thing all right and then you get to
def you get to pull different levers and
then you get to put a spectrum and on
one end you're going to have what
probably what you're probably meaning by
investing which is lower risk let's
diversify this is wealth growth and
compound interest in your dividend
collection stuff okay and then on the
other hand and then you can start doing
some higher risk things maybe actually
picking out your own portfolio
individually taking stocks and whatever
it is and
continue working your way up
as risk starts increasing uh so is your
potential return obviously and then you
have what we're calling gambling right
which is ultra high risk right like low
probability but but really high impact
potentially
uh speculation so there is there is your
your spectrum and along the way
everybody is guessing right like warren
buffett obviously is a great investor
but he gets it wrong sometimes too right
like the airlines in kovitz was a great
example with it so he takes his little
loss and whatever and call it a day but
his his approach is is one that requires
decades
this other one is just you're just
pulling it up and so you're speculating
from both ends of it it's how much am i
willing
to lose or how much do i want to make
and then you can even make it justice
you can get
you can make it um
you can gamble responsibly right if if
you have a hundred thousand dollars and
you go to someone saying dude don't do
these out of the money stock options
because you're going to lose your money
it's like yeah i could lose 100 of my
money but i'll take a thousand of those
dollars put them on this side of the
spectrum and i'll take the other 99 over
here i've seen multiple times people
take
1 000 turn it into a hundred thousand
dollars overnight all right so
was that risking or was that super
intelligent diversified approach to what
was money risk management
yeah 100 luck yeah
the incredible amount of luck uh but
still it happens and it's like well
worst case scenario which was the most
likely i would have had 99 000 left
right and i got
i hit the jackpot and so now i have
twice as much money as i started with
it's irresponsible to take the hundred
thousand dollars and do that yeah all
right that's interesting because it's
exactly the same as what well not
exactly the same but very similar to
what uh ask sebby said when he came on
our podcast he was no is beat the bush
he said that you should place your bets
obviously you know you should be doing
the long-term you know growth investing
and stuff like that but at the same time
it is important on occasion to put some
money here put some money there that
could potentially you know explode and
and you know skyrocket your account if
you want to become that type of wealthy
so here's here's a cool thing right
before coronavirus one of the things
that that
uh led to be being removed i was
i i said to myself all right now this is
big and i wanted to start this
conversation we've already had it a few
times with the infinite margin like you
had a handful of events
now let's take it to the next level i
really want to see people on tv mad
about the situation so i'm going to
rent out a casino like one of those you
know concert venues a place i'm gonna do
this competitive day trading like a
tournament type thing where you have 10
or 12 competitors on stage on the front
it was like an esports tournament right
trading live with the actual stock
market oh my gosh and yoloing the crap
out of this so it's gonna it's gonna
have the format of a video game
tournament like these esports that's
amazing
yeah i would watch that yeah
ppv yeah do what you just you give
everyone 10 grand
i mean there's a lot of laws around that
so
i actually created this thing i had it
all set up so i'm familiar very well
with what the restrictions are but even
more than that it was like let's take a
dave portnoy and a jim cramer and you
know if you saw oh yeah you know what
you call it trading spaces the homeless
guy from the street like just get a
little bit of everything just to see
yeah to see what wins if you wat chris
moneymaker for that first world series
of poker wasn't a good poker player but
it was fun to watch and he you know and
he won because he was lucky obviously
there's lux so let's just you know do
this yolo thing
and and and no other place than in a
casino right because i want the world to
know that we're playing with the stock
market from las vegas
um then coronavirus came and killed my
dreams but now i'm bringing it back and
that's going to happen much bigger this
time around because um let's just see
some opportunities open i want an invite
to that i want to see it sounds
incredible yeah yeah absolutely so how
do you oh so how do you feel wall street
bets has changed investing because i
think very much it's it shifted away
from it it almost seems like now
people are
no longer interested in safe fundamental
stocks because they're like why would i
wait a year to make seven percent when
all of these other people are
trading momentum stocks now or meme
stocks and they're making that in a few
hours
it's a great question is it's not that
wall street bets created that is that
these people were created before wall
street bets there's an entire mindset in
this generation like millennials on down
where they were impacted by this 2008
financial crisis it was the banks that
made them
graduate college with huge loans and you
know no prospect for a job and maybe
move into their parents basement and
maybe their parents lose their house
like
it's just very few opportunities and you
can see that even to this day
millennials and gen z they have it worse
off than their parents that like if you
were to make a comparison they're having
kids later
so you have this kind of distrust to the
system this this mindset that starts
creating like this gig economy that
leads to uber or whatever you know
becoming influencers online let's let's
hustle let's try to make some money on
the side because i'm
i have to fend for myself right so that
mentality starts creating itself right
there and then people say okay well
there you have the stock market and we
know that it's just wild because it can
go up or down and people tinker with it
all the time like
not too long ago several months ago that
was the um i forgot what the name of
this company was
some some fund was being insanely
irresponsible with derivatives and they
ended up like spooking
the entire stock market and dropped
viacom's stock price by 50 percent
nothing to do with viacom it just had to
do with derivatives and this domino
effect forget their name
um
and uh and it's like well but come there
the fundamentals are the same why did
this thing drop fifty percent they
didn't announce any news it was some
other irresponsible player that had this
domino effect that that created this
thing so it's like well i'm gonna go in
and out and i'm gonna use it too can't
beat them join them that philosophy has
kind of
[Music]
continued up until this day
my my personal thing about wall street
is i actually unlike popular belief i
love wall street i love the system
i just think it needs fixing to some
extent all right like the the purpose
for these things existing
is
to raise capital for companies all right
people forget about that but the other
you know just a couple weeks ago i had a
reuters um journalist say hey amc the
stock is up because everyone's talking
about this thing and the ceo just now is
going to do an additional offering and
in the prospectus it says these stocks
are not worth what you say you know what
people are paying for means so he admits
there that he's scamming people and then
he says there's going to be a larger
supply thereby
supposedly reducing their price and
people still bought it the price even
went higher like what what what's
happening here isn't this crazy do you
worry that it's ever going in the
direction of being like a pump and dump
where everyone collectively gets
together and say hey we like this stock
we're just gonna buy it up and if all of
us buy
a thousand dollars worth we could
influence the price this much and we
just gotta sell i do um
i like
it's not that i worry that it's gonna
happen it's more
it's more i'd like it to not turn into
that be turned into the conversation uh
because then it's not productive anymore
and then it's actually counterproductive
to the system right like one of the
greatest things about the market is
price discovery so more people that are
in it the
more efficient that process can be so i
think that you
uh the that if you have people
thinking they're going to make a quick
buck by pushing the prices around
then
then i'd like for that to not happen but
it cannot happen that easily what we saw
with gamestop is so much more than just
a pump and up like it's easy to see
these guys like the stock and these guys
were shorting it a lot and it was a
short squeeze and it was just very
sophisticated surgical maneuver with
luck and all these different things they
tried out with apple or whatever it's
not going to happen try that with penny
stocks that will right
but that was one of the reasons why when
i started wall street bets it was like
no penny stocks because that that's too
easy um
and then then eventually
we ended up increasing the bar to i
forgot what th it was both the stock
price and the market cap
amount just to just to prevent that kind
of dialogue
it's not not productive and it's also
gonna get unwarranted attention yeah did
you yourself get in on gamestop amc
no um
no i live in mexico right now and so
ever since i moved in mexico moving
money from my u.s broker to mexico and
back like it's just such a pain in the
butt and then taxes become really
complicated so i stopped trading
individual stocks and stock options
since since i got there in 2014 i now do
like futures and forex like i do my best
where i can do it easily right now why
do you why did you move to mexico and
where did you move from
i was in dc in the last place but in the
us i've lived in dc chicago like salt
lake city utah moved around a bit
um meg i was actually born in mexico and
i lived there until i was like 12 13.
always wanted to go back opportunity
popped up went down there for a little
bit and i was like i like it here sorry
but you still do yolo bets yeah but with
just futures and other other things i
use different instruments and do you do
you you can't use robinhood anymore i
can do you use it
no no i don't use any usb like i have
i have
brokers that have my investments
non-yellows so everything got rolled up
at the either e-trade or a td ameritrade
so all my brokers that i have are now
those two
and what do you think of the
gamification of trading on robinhood
i think it's great right you have
well first of all i'm going to say
having confetti animations or whatever
is not going to force somebody to buy
stuff i
i don't know really i hate to interrupt
i liked the confetti i'm good remember
those are the good old days and you got
a free stock and you scratched it off i
loved it i like the confetti i love it i
like it too yeah i love it all right
what is that it's funny you're not gonna
you're not gonna go out there and buy
you you enjoy it so if you have to pick
between brokers to yolo with maybe
you're like i like the one with confetti
yeah right you've already made your
decision to yolo or right like and so
uh so i don't think that that in itself
encourages the crazy behavior i think
that that decision is made
it's
either made or going to be made
throughout the natural progression of
these people's adventures in the stocks
uh but i think that it's great because
it educates people if you if you buy a
stock in tesla like i just bought a
share all right and
now i'm hoping to get rich i'm going to
check the stocks today it's up two
percent cool that's exactly what it was
supposed to do the next day it goes down
two percent like why is it going down
like what is the news you know when it
goes up it's no big deal when it goes
down there's gotta be news right
start looking it up and they can't find
any news on tesla but then they're like
all right there's this dude called
powell
jerome powell he's talking about some
interest what does that have to do with
anything right next thing you know
they're understanding monetary policy
and what has to do with the interest
rates how these things are
interconnected in the bond yields and
whatever it might be and all of a sudden
you have a person that's become educated
because of their two percent you know in
tesla
that's that's one example maybe it
doesn't go that crazy but but once you
have that stock in your thing so the
gamification process encourages
that process it's not scary there's
confetti scratch your thing off click
the button in fact robinhood is funny
because they
stock options which are trickier uh or
they can be trickier than regular stocks
uh definitely it can be they can they
can be intimidating when you open an
options chain on a regular broker and
have like a gazillion numbers that are
flashing robin hood says all right you
want a stock option sure no problem do
you think the stock's going to go up or
down and then you answer with the arrow
with the color-coded arrow it's like so
they make it so easy oh yeah yeah they
don't even have an option chain it looks
different you like buy sell call put
it's just like any other option
so well i have to say yeah i didn't
understand options but when you go
through robinhood do you think it's
going to go up or down down when do you
think it's going to go down this date
how much do you think it's going to go
down this much
there you go that's what you want i mean
that's wonderful you don't have to know
black shells pricing model like it's
it's cool because it's like whoa why
does this thing go down so much right
or up so much or whatever it is and so
that's that's cool because it encourages
experimentation and fun and learning and
and i think it's a it's it's like a
gateway drug for people
but are you concerned though i think the
problem with gamification is that uh
from the sec's perspective robinhood is
is gamifying a system that benefits the
more the users trade
and generally the more users trade the
more money they lose at robin hood's
benefit yeah do you think that there's
any sort of conflict of interest no no
robin
i followed everything up until losing it
robin has benefited robin hood is
indifferent as to whether you lose money
they will make their they will make
their money from number of troops well
let me clarify that um generally the
more people trade the more likely they
are to lose yes so by robin hood
encouraging users to trade more at their
benefits basically people are more
likely to lose money there you go so uh
is there a perverse incentive no because
well first of all there's a lot of
criticism towards
the the encouraging so the first thing
is how do they encourage a lot of
trading by making them free right and so
then that
that takes us to this payment for order
flow concept and so then you're starting
questioning execution of these things
and i don't
as a sub part of your question i don't
really care about like i don't think
that payment for order flow is bad the
rules are such that the payment photo
flow have to give you the same or better
prices than you would on the exchange so
the prices themselves are good this
whole front-running thing is like silly
um i personally
i don't like payment further for myself
because i need a fast execution i need
pennies on the dollar i do like charts
i'm more technical than meme stock or
yellow type stuff uh so i choose to pay
a commission for my trades because
that's what works for me you take keith
gill it takes 50 000 grand and turn it
into 50 million dollars like these guys
don't care if you got stiffed a couple
of cents on this thing because their
approach is a different one that suits
them so
so on the payment for water flow
standpoint not really worried
the let's encourage a lot of activity on
there
uh
it it
i think that as long as people are aware
that what they are doing is risky which
oftentimes they do especially after they
lose money
then
then it's on these individuals there's
there's gamblers right there's there's a
like an addiction of gambling and
gamblers anonymous and those people have
a problem and that problem is usually
hey this activity is now affecting the
livelihood of
you and your family whatever it is go
get some help those people exist whether
they be in vegas or whether they be on
the stock market
for the majority of people they say i
lost money that hurt
i don't want to do that again so some
people are so risk-averse so like never
again close it and uninstall the app and
call it a day
for a lot of people it's like no no i
think i can learn from this thing right
like i think i can do it better next
time as was the case with me i would
make tons of money and i would lose tons
of money and when i make tons of money i
would start seeing dollar signs i'm like
i just need to do that six more times
and i'll have 600 million dollars right
like because if you do the math and
you know then of course you can't do
that six more times and so eventually
the the trajectory that at least i took
was from like crazier risk to more
systematic and so then it's all of a
sudden things about risk management and
you know putting a little bit more
science to it
and
uh and that's the name of the game what
did i walk away with even if i had lost
money i walked away with tons of
knowledge i am now a better fundamental
investor
right because of that natural curiosity
than most people would probably imagine
so what are your own personal
investments looking like
i'm a boring investor so i have like snp
in the nasdaq it's a little bit heavier
uh and that's it on the u.s side right
and that's what percentage would you say
that is oh what of just like
total yep
uh
[Music]
that's an excellent question i would
probably say
20 percent
okay and then the other 80.
you want to hear the question
no i have seen i have it
build a bear no there is there is uh
you know
liquid like a savings or whatever it is
with the bank we have real estate we
have crypto which is something i'm
getting really heavy into
uh and then and then other investments
a very large part in private equity
really because these are the the uh
pre-ipo type investments now i know this
may seem like a silly question but how
do you yourself make money
uh i make money in lots of different
ways so i have
this is a casino sir
i i do make money with trading right so
uh but but it's no longer the thing that
i sit there all day long doing right
like stuff no no trading short term
stuff like that
i now just go into the high propensity
i've
seen this enough times and lost enough
money to know that there are some really
big opportunities that even in regular
investing you know that like this is the
go all-in moment because the stocks are
down fifty percent like pandemic last
year two thousand eight and then that
that thing happens
for more frequently with trading where
it's like whatever your style is i'm
like this is a three times a year type
situation i'm gonna put a lot of money
on this bank right and then it's very
high propensity to pay out like you know
over 90 and and the returns are insane
so
and then there's smaller ones of those
opportunities that come in and so if i
happen to be on my phone and i'm
checking these things and my setups are
there or i feel that there's a short
term thing i'll go in there and that
that generates a fair amount of money
but i'll do that maybe
anywhere between one to four times a
month that's all that it really takes to
do that and then uh
but that's boring and i don't want to
just do that all day long so the things
that i make money from is i do speaking
arrangements i wrote a book i'm probably
writing another one i'm doing this las
vegas thing
uh this the um
what do you call it the competitive day
trading thing that turned into because
of the regulations this is kind of cool
the sec it turns out is not that much of
an impediment to doing this it's more
the fcc so i want to pay the winner a
million bucks and so in order to do that
you have to
you know you can't give it to your
buddies to be competitors and i need to
make sure it's fair so then that created
an entire reality tv show that's
attached to her right so i just signed
with a really big production company
that's going to
to handle that so you have your reality
tv show leading up to the final event
and so that's a a money maker there you
know like
the movie that i created uh making deals
with uh the crypto um is is a good one
i've created so i i
i'm now getting big into crypto but i
still my passion is wall street and i
know that those two things are emerging
so i've created this platform that is
combining crypto with um
regular stocks or traditional finance so
you can now actually invest
from the crypto side into the stock
market and create these kind of i want
to there's a tiny little tangent but i
think it's exciting right like to
showcase the technology of what it is
that we created on the crypto side
you guys know the etfs are right right
so etfs they have to if you want to
rebalance them like to make them ememe
stock etf you have to like file with the
sec and you have to pay money and wait
in the improvement and whatever and then
eventually
you can do that on the fly on the
blockchain without having to do any of
these things so i'm creating an etf that
will trade on the stock market
whose sole underlying is an etp which is
what we're calling exchange traded
portfolios it's like a blockchain
version of it and that blockchain
version etf all it does is it copies the
greatest investment couple of our
generation
nancy pelosi and company mm-hmm
excellent like they're 20
stock markets they've proven they have
112 annualized return with 12 drawdown
they have really impeccable stats
you can now trade real time with that
and so uh
now when you mean real time aren't we
seeing with within a 30-day wait yeah
yeah yeah you won't be able to get their
exact returns yeah if they happen to
have
incredible luck with timing you know
because sometimes politicians can be
really really lucky with timing maybe
you're not going to get that exact
little bump but you'll be able to get
i would love that honestly we should be
able to that should here's the thing
because recently they've wanted to uh i
think they've actually just banned
uh uh uh policymakers from buying
individual stocks
and i don't know if they passed that or
not i haven't i have to go look i think
they just did okay and they've uh so
basically they could they could buy
individual stocks but they have to give
45 days notice to the public and it has
to be approved
they that's good for you they have to
they have to they have to hold that
investment for a year and if they want
to sell again another 45 days notice and
it has to be approved
but those are under special
circumstances but otherwise they must
buy into a mutual fund or an etf that
tracks the broad market
that was just something that i covered
later on on friday's video and i covered
it friday friday's video because it came
out thursday night okay that's right i
haven't seen it yet yeah okay and i
titled my video banned from investing
but here's the thing about it i don't
know enough about this so i'm so i'm
gonna try not to say too much about it
but i'll say what i've seen in the past
with these things like this insider
trading thing has is not new it's
happened forever right and the first
time that i saw it i was outraged like
there's some some um
congress people they were buying
property in some state right before they
approved the railroad to go through it
what you know like inside information
maybe it wasn't the stock market and
same outrage people got really upset so
they passed the law of no insider
trading fairness act of america
whatever year it is and what the rules
say is you can no longer buy like
property in the state of wyoming you
know between the days of whatever 2005
and 2006 if you were about to pass a law
about a real like it was just very
specific to do not repeat that one
particular maneuver again uh and i'm
inclined to think that the
but now i have to go read it before i
speak i i guess i'm hoping that the rule
is actually the way that you've
described it like once wants to find
princeton because that would be the fair
thing
but in the meantime i'm still really
excited about the the prospect of being
able to mimic because i still think that
the congress uh has the ability to be
better traders and the
general americans and so anyway so i so
i make money with that related stuff and
and uh
yeah i don't know that entrepreneur
speaking of that i found this to be a
very interesting video this uh this guy
nob jaws over at market sentiment he
analyzes all of these stocks and
including the stocks on wall street bets
he's he's the one who's put together in
the past this entire spreadsheet
analyzing the mentions the daily
mentions of every single stock on wall
street bets and then analyzing its
performance this guy is incredible but
he looked at the past performance of
congress members and determined that
overall they do beat the s p 500 by a
little bit
uh but it's skewed by the by the few
people like the pelosi's who end up
doing really well
but most people who copy these within 30
days
barely beat the s p 500 it's by like one
percent and it's not worth over 10 000
different trades copying them except
it's like the you know the top five i
think so so here's here's what's
interesting right like as we're because
this is happening by the way this isn't
just a joke
and and and doing that and doing all
these filings and work on these things
like all right well what happens if
pelosi resigns right like you know
amongst many other different things and
so the way that we're solving that is
something that goes in that direction
where it's like well that's okay i have
my my ledger here of potential
politicians all right like and these are
their stats like if they're baseball
players and this one right here they and
you can see all their past performance
and then you could just kind of
this thing happens on the blockchain
there's like a governance based thing
people vote community whatever and so
basically the the community's gonna take
a vote and select the new politician
that's going to be the key winner so
that you know i i do figure that if you
take everyone as an average you have
like 435 congress people plus 100
senators i mean you have like over 500
people you're probably going to get an
average as an average but yeah i think
that people are going to go for the ones
that have a better track record what are
your thoughts about alternative
investments whether that be nfts art
collectibles what are your thoughts on
that
i made the mistake of assuming that
crypto was bitcoin or whatever coin for
too long like i i knew exactly what it
was at the beginning i even had you know
gotten into it myself never made it part
of wall street best because the
execution the difficulty of getting
involved was just too high and i never
reevaluated that stance and i regret not
doing that because
because the crypto is so much more than
just coins right like it is an entire
system that is mind baffling and i could
do an entire hour just on that but the
so so i start seeing these nfts and i
start seeing these rocks going for a
million dollars and i can make quick
assumptions about it and say okay the
tulip mania we got in the situation here
but i'm not going to make that mistake
again so i'm going to go in there and
i'm actually going to buy some nfts and
see what it's about
um
and i think
there is definitely some serious staying
power there it's incredibly fascinating
nfts
uh
the the core definition non-fungible
tokens are just like a data file that
has information in it and it's on a
blockchain and you can do a lot of stuff
with it
now it's they're currently their use is
currently associated with here's a
picture of this pixelated whatever you
know sell it for a lot of money but
that's not what the technology is that
is one use of that application the
actual nft application i think has
tremendous investment potential i
touched on the fractionalized real
estate
you know i was i probably shouldn't say
who but there's a very high profile
famous real estate individual
you know who approached me was like dude
we we need to marry these nfts with real
estate and
uh
and because i had this preconceived
notion i'm like this is a really cool
thing people can just buy little pieces
of it you have the art you have the i do
my picasso and i can sell i think that's
really cool too and and then you have
the other one that's currently in
existence is the you know 10 000
pre-generated let's make a community and
sell it to them
i
you know there's we are also in a heated
situation where there's a lot of money
flowing in a lot of excitement that's
going to die off there's going to be
some stuff but you know it's talking
about
regulation uh uh
with i could say who brittany kaiser
she's like the the whistleblower the
cambridge analytic uh we're talking
about other crypto stuff and and she's
got this uh
you know she's trying to get into the
lobbying world and she's got all these
things registered i'm like why don't you
give
the office of the congressperson an nft
you tell that congressperson this nft is
programs that it's going to give you
every month one million dollars
of the owner of this nft so long as the
mechanism by which you can receive that
million dollars continues to be illegal
right that's the rule right so it's like
this automatic lobbying contraption
where you don't have to call and wine
and dine whatever you're you know people
that are in the house of representatives
specifically the two-year term people
they just do campaigning all year long
like it's incredible so you don't have
to campaign anymore here's your money
just make sure that you don't pass any
laws that prevents that from happening
because then we don't want to break the
law and we'll have to shut off your nft
like cool stuff there thank you so much
for coming on it's fantastic meeting you
yeah no likewise this is a lot of fun
this is probably the most prompt uh
podcast we've ever done in terms of like
starting starting right on time ending
right on time i want to respect your
time thank you and we really appreciate
you coming on yes thank you so much for
having me yeah thank you guys uh make
sure to subscribe oh you want to tell
them to hit the like button you just hit
the like button
subscribe and make sure to get your free
stock down below in the description
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
awesome appreciate it thank you so much
man i really appreciate that